I'd like to turn now to the high
representative vice president of the
commission Mr Joseph borell welcome to
you
and commissioner
lenic and I'd like to call on the high
representative to take the
floor here president
sen
president ladies and gentlemen members
dear commissioner manic
colleague I've just returned from a
five-day mission to the countries of the
Middle East Arab countries and
Palestine there I witnessed the high
degree of emotion with which uh what's
happening there is being followed by all
and it ought it ought to be possible to
have a debate on what is going on there
without emotion and uh looking further
Beyond towards the building of Peace it
is the case that on October the 7th the
world witnessed the greatest uh Massacre
of Jews that had ever occurred since the
second world war and then uh witnessed
the bombing of Gaza defined by the
United Nations or described by the
United Nations as an unprecedented
humanitarian catastrophe but not a
natural catastrophe not a natural
disaster but it's something that was
brought about as a result of a blockade
preventing essential supplies for the
population survival from getting through
which is another kind of
Massacre is there no interpretation asks
the speaker your inter English interpret
trust that that can be
heard
I'm going to ask for extra
time
president
president I was saying that I'm just
back from A5 day trip to where this uh
uh dramatic conflict is uh uh underway
and that we ought to be able to get over
the degree of emotion that uh is uh
overwhelming those involved we ought to
be able to look further towards a future
of Peace because they ought that ought
to be possible because we are witnessing
the greatest uh Massacre or pgam of uh
Jews since the second world
war we're seeing how the um bombing in
Gaza has caused an unprecedented
disaster not a natural one but uh it's
been brought about by uh man uh by
humankind because the supply of basic uh
Provisions has been uh stopped uh the
United Nations described this as
Carnage and it ought to be possible to
recognize the right of Israel to defend
itself and simultaneously to uh be IND
about what's happening for us to be
indignant about what's happening in Gaza
to civilians we ought to be able to
defend the israeli's rights to have a
state without that
meaning we'd be criticized for being
partisan it ought to be possible to
criticize the policies of Israel because
governmental or or countries policies
can be
criticized without ones to being uh
accused us of not liking the Jews let's
not jumble things up one thing is to
criticize a country and a different
thing is to re is to express rejection
for part of the population but I also
saying that uh what one sometimes
sees the Expressions uh are of the
ugliest side of uh the Jewish attitude
doesn't help when describe them it
doesn't help the Palestinian cause the
international
Court uh
has begun investigations and its Chief
prosecutor Karen cam who I've been in
touch with are investigating what's
going on and have La have sent very
serious warnings to both parties stating
that Israel also has clear obligations
in the context of the war that is waging
against Hamas not just moral obligations
but also legal obligations uh arising
from the law on armed law on armed
conflict and having to do uh with the
prevention of access to um basic
supplies by the population and that
every school every hospital every church
every mask is a uh an area that's
protected and unless they lose that
status as protected areas because
they're being used for military purposes
then they need to be respected as such
and if there's any doubt as to whether a
given territory or a given property has
or has not lost its status as a
protected place the attacker has to
assume that it's still protected by
default or show proof that it has
forfeited that
status and has to make it possible for
the civilians there to
leave
similarly indiscriminate rocket attacks
by Hamas against Israel are also an
infringement of international
humanitarian
law and I was one of the earliest to
people to say that preventing access of
water or access to water and electricity
and and staple supplies is an
infringement of international
humanitarian law and the prosecutor of
the international criminal
court is saying it's not me he he is
saying and has told Israel that uh it
should be making efforts without further
delay to ensure the access uh of
supplies and medicines and anesthetics
on the part of the
civilians the European Union is
extremely concerned about what's
happening and more
specifically we've expressed Our concern
about the attacks by Israeli sett
settlers against
civilians in the West Bank and elsewhere
and these are ongoing and the prosecutor
of the ICC has done the
same as you
know I represent the
council and that's all member states and
you're also aware that it's not
easy because sometimes the member states
have not spoken with a single
voice if you take for example the vote
uh in the general assembly of the United
Nations where eight of Our member states
voted in favor of a humanitarian pores
and four voted against and the rest
abstained there is a joint position in
the European
Council which does speak in favor of
pauses plural and humanitarian corridors
and requests that when Israel exercises
her right to uh defense to defend
herself it should do so in line with the
international laws on
War
but to date different leaders in Europe
have expressed different views on the
way in which Israel is exercising that
right to defend to defense and when
there isn't a joint position the high
representative can't express that joint
position because it doesn't exist but he
has to go on working to see that it is
built he has to ensure to try to ensure
that in future the member states can
converge in such a way that they can
bring some uh geopolitical pressure to
Bear geopolitical influence to bear in
this conflict and this is what we're
trying to
do fully persuaded that there cannot be
a military solution to this conflict one
cannot kill an
idea the only way is to get a better
idea and the better idea here can only
be to recognize that when you have two
peoples that have been fighting over the
same land for more than 100 years they
need to be able to live together if the
International Community is committed to
that and the International Community has
not yet been thus in the 30 years since
the uh Oso agreements we've been
repeating two State solution solution
the solution is two states the solution
is two states we've repeated that we've
done very little or nothing to bring it
about we thought that the idea that the
the the problem could be
compiz comp compartmentalized sorry
because one side was already peaceful
and the other wasn't but this drama
that's exploded has shown us that there
needs to be peace not just between
Palestine and Israel but but also
between Israel and Palestine and for
that to be the case all of
us notably we Europeans need to become
committed to getting over the huge grief
and pain that these events begun by
hamas's
attacks Beyond its borders in Gaza
brought
about this could be the opportunity for
peace to be built and this is what the
European Union wishes to do we have put
forward proposals three yeses three NOS
Gaza can't be under hamas's control in
the future it can't be controlled by
Israel in the future it cannot be
divided three negatives three positives
there has to be a Palestine Authority in
uh Gaza as well the Israelis have to
commit themselves not just to build
Finance construction but we Europeans
also need to be part of a solution that
can only uh involve something that we've
been expressing the need for for years
which is peaceful coexistence between
two uh peoples that are in Conflict
which need to be able to share the same
area the same land in peace thank you
very
much thank you Mr barell now on behalf
of the European commission commissioner
lenic has the
floor Mr President honorable members of
the European Parliament distinguished
High representative Borel let me the
outset reiterate in the strongest terms
our condemnation of the heinous attack
by Hamas on Israel last month and
underline that Israel has the right to
defend itself while respecting
international law in particular
International humanitarian
law also as stated by President fion
earlier
today we wholeheartedly welcome the
agreement reached on the release of the
50 hostages and on a pause of
hostilities we stress at the same time
the urgent need for all hostages to be
released immediately and we will work
with our humanarian partners to use the
pause for a humanitarian surge in
Gaza allow me to focus on three issues
in my intervention the humanitarian
situation in Gaza including the question
of access into Gaza the European Union's
humanitarian response and the Outlook
Beyond the immediate humanitarian crisis
first on the humanitarian situation in G
Gaza there has been no let up in the
intense bombardment and fighting in Gaza
casualty rates remain very high at least
12,700 Palestinians are reported killed
including a very high proportion of
women and
children 1.7 million people are
displaced within
Gaza thousands are currently on the
Move we are seeing ongoing attacks on
and fighting around medical facilities
which are protected under the
international humanitarian
law there is an acute shortage across
Gaza of all the most basic necessities
food medicines including
anesthetics water according to the
United Nations
food assistance currently covers only
10% of the minimum caloric
intake medical facilities are either on
the brink of collapse or have already
shut
down only nine out of 35 hospitals in
Gaza are reportedly still functioning
and this only
partially the toll on the United Nations
and on Aid and medical workers in Gaza
has been appalling
at least 108 staff members of the unra
alone have been killed since the
beginning of this
crisis humanitarian access into Gaza
remains extremely challenging over the
last month fewer than 50 trucks a day on
average have been going into Gaza
through the Rafa Crossing from Egypt
this is vul
inadequate and for several days last
week not a single truck was able to get
in the acute shortage of fuel in Gaza
remains a major
constraint the agreement on 18 November
by Israel to allow 120,000 lers of fuel
for humanitarian operations is a step in
the right direction but will only cover
one third of the daily critical
needs without fuel trucks cannot move
and humanarian actors cannot operate
fuel is vital for hospitals for clean
water it is needed for treatment of
sewage to avert the looming Public
Health crisis and for mobile networks
without which no humanitarian assistance
can be delivered inside Gaza the amount
of fuel available to humanitarian actors
in any humanitarian crisis should depend
on their needs and needs
alone second on EU response
as president fion announced we have
quadrupled our humanitarian funding for
the occupied Palestinian territory to
more than 100 million
EUR this is being rolled out as we
speak supporting our accredited Partners
on the ground the United Nations the Red
Cross and red crescent and international
non-governmental
organizations they are Distributing food
and water maintaining Emergency Medical
Services where possible he helping with
mass casualty management ensuring basic
hygiene and so on and we are
continuously ramping up our European in
kind response there have already been 15
EU humanitarian airbridge flights so far
for Gaza and more are in the pipeline
these are cargo flights for our
humanitarian partners and for our member
States president fion was on the ground
in Alish last weekend during the loading
of one of our
flights most of the cargo from these
flights has already gone into Gaza we
have moreover established a joint
coordination cell with the Red Cross and
red crescent to organize and channel our
assistance in parallel we are helping
the Egyptian red crescent further build
up its logistical capacity and through
the Union Civil protection mechanism we
are supporting Egypt's Frontline Medical
Response
the key challenge to repeat is access
access for humanitarian assistance into
Gaza in the first instance this means
allowing a sufficient number of trucks
into Gaza through Rafa and if possible
opening another land Crossing but we
should also explore all other possible
avenues for allowing additional
assistance into
Gaza ensuring adequate humanitarian
access will also require putting in
place urgent and and extended
humanitarian pauses throughout Gaza and
for a sufficient number of days as
called for last week by the United
Nations security Council in its
resolution
2712 which was facilitated by
Malta we hope that the agreement on a
pause of hostilities that has just been
reached will allow for a substantial
surge in humanitarian Aid delivery into
and within Gaza and we certainly hope
that this will not be a
oneoff third on the prospects for Gaza
and the broader Israeli Palestine
conflict I representative spoke about
that
already even as we respond to the
immediate humanitarian challenges and do
everything we can to promote respect for
international humanitarian law we need a
step change in efforts to put work on a
political solution to the conflict
back on track this means
reinvigorating and accelerating efforts
that have long been stalled towards a
two-state solution as the only way
forward that can offer hope to both
Palestinians and
Israelis more specifically this will
require working towards a solution for
Gaza as an integral part of a solution
to the broader Israeli Palestinian issue
preventing any forcible displac M of
Palestinians out of
Gaza preventing any return of Hamas to
Gaza as well as any long-term Israeli
security presence in
Gaza urgently de escalating the
situation in the West Bank and in
particular stopping the extremist
settler violence which has increased
dramatically in recent weeks and
supporting a legitimate legitimate
Palestinian Authority in administering
Gaza there is no alternative to engaging
now if we are to break the spiral of
violence restore hope to people in
Palestine and Israel and prevent broader
instability in the Middle East thank
you
thank thank you very much commissioner
we now move on to the
speakers from our own assembly we'll
start with M Raza
yuk dear colleagues I have the feeling
that we see the world too
simplistically when we divide ourselves
into either pro-israel or Pro
Palestinian and when many are repeating
two states
solution but this Mantra will not work
unless there is a fundamental agreement
among Israel's neighbors that Hamas must
not happen again that the Jewish state
has the right to to exist I was shocked
when after the bloody attack by Hamas we
saw the celebration in Gaza and not only
Gaza
squares as long as Hamas exists it is
difficult for me to believe in the
success of the two-state
solution Hamas must be destroyed that
must be the task of the entire
Democratic
Community Hamas Isis Al-Qaeda
are the same the same cancer they will
be reborn again and again until the
course of the cancer is isolated
including terrorist states such as Iran
or Russia we have two Wars of a similar
nature in the both neighborhoods of
European Union both are aimed at
destroying Democratic states Israel and
Ukraine so many people are suff uing
Europe's future security longlasting
peace depend on our response the
challenge is clear democracies must
win
thank thank you very much our next
speaker is Pedro
Marcus thank you Mr President I
representative commissioner colleagues
as the sun rose today a beam of Hope
Came to Israel is and Gaza after weeks
of indiscriminate bombing a humanitarian
Tru was achieved last night this must be
the beginning of the end of the
nightmare that started with the terror
of Hamas and the death of more than
1,000
Israelis but punishing the civilian
population in Gaza was also not
admissible and it is not even effective
for peace is the only way to really
eradicate the ideology of amas from
Palestine and the region
every one of the thousands of civilians
that lost their lives in Gaza brought
Israel not one millimeter closer to long
lasting peace this Bloodshed must end
for good a permanent ceasefire the full
release of the hostages is urgent and
needed we need a true political strategy
with a viable political Horizon the far
right in Israel has no permanent
solution to this conflict we as
Europeans we truly need to commit
ourselves to the global Global effort of
peace and the two- State solution thank
you thank
you thank you very much Miss Hilda vaans
is the next speaker thank
you thank you president ladies and
gentlemen so we woke up this morning
with the best news we've heard this week
so finally there's a temporary
ceasefire and a promise of 50 hostages
being released so let us let this be the
start of a longer lasting ceasefire and
the release of all
hostages and this conflict that's
already lasted far too long because it
is a a genuine humanitarian disaster
ladies and gentlemen the biggest murder
of Jews since the second world war
bombing schools and hospitals two
million people in Gaza who are looking
for water food Staples medicines safety
and then the hostages hell on Earth
Earth they call it and this hell on
Earth has to be put a stop to Mr borell
you gave a clear message today and I
think you were actually stronger than
ever before in your statement on the
conflict today and I'd like to thank you
very warmly for that this is the Europe
that I'm happy to see rather than the
kopon that we saw at the start of the
conflict unfortunately so I'm very
pleased to see the the power that you
exuded today and I'm proud colleagues of
the visit of Mr decro the Prime Minister
of
Belgium it shows to me as a proud
Belgian how a small country can be great
because Belgium has played its role
colleagues contrary to a number of other
countries in the EU who are happy to
have friendship links or worried about
the past catching them up but for me
this is a wakeup call for Europe and
here I'm turning to the commission
because really this also shows our
political
weaknesses uh you said uh 30 years there
been a plea for the two-state solution
but we haven't done anything to bring
that two-state solution any closer to
reality and in when it comes to Europe
we haven't played a meaningful role
we've always had to look to the US and
to
Qatar and president you let the council
and the commission speak up beyond their
time as the main negotiator I would like
be able to make my point we find
colleagues that Europe has to be
reformed if we want to be a geopolitical
player then I hope that you will agree
to ke for Hof's report soon in the vote
that there should be a reform of Europe
and that will be able to play a main
role in these sort of conflicts thank
you here
Jord Mr
Jord
today we see a small ray of light after
50 days of darkness of war and of
death the 4 day uh truce is uh welcome
with the release of hostages it's a step
in the right direction but it's not
enough we need a permanent ceasefire and
the release of all hostages as well as
an increase in humanitarian
Aid after the Abominable actions of
Hamas on the 7th of October Israel had
to respond but the Israeli military
response against
Hamas did not have to turn into a war on
the civilians of
Gaza the response has been a
indiscriminate disproportionate
response in an area uh in the Gaza Strip
where one in every 10 people has been
assassinated these are um innocent
civilians many of them are
children
this has already become the most deadly
Conflict for children of recent
decades international law and
international humanitarian law sets out
standards that have to be
respected um to respect the human being
and that this goes for all
wars after this terrible War we will
have to try to heal these awful wounds
but also this interminable conflict
between the Israelis and Palestinians uh
that has gone on for so long
we have seen uh the conflict management
that so many people thought were the
solution has brought us no level of
violence is um
sustainable because um conflicts will
always use uh this violence we want to
see Gaza without Hammer but without a
blockade and without occupation uh we
need to see a legitimate effective uh
government that the people can accept as
their
own uh Gaza has to be part of the
solution for all of the occupied
Palestinian territories and uh will also
mean more security for Israel thank
you Mr her has the floor
now good
morning thank you
golden mayor stated that the war in
Palestine and in Israel would end when
the Palestinians love their children
more than they hate the Israelis that
that's not happened yet it's a long way
off it has to be said also that we
cooperated because we have financed
books in the occupied territories that
only Foster hatred of Israel and Foster
the whole culture of uh uh systematic
terrorism in Gaza there was an
enthusiastic Applause for what happened
on the 7th of October and in the
occupied territories it was also
applauded palestine's authorities who
are being presented here as being
wonderful
uh are still uh continuing with this
attitude when people are being killed so
therefore Israel has a right to end this
war by ending Hamas once and forever by
putting an end to it once and for all
some people don't want this apparently
here to see this happen it is is going
to happen we're sorry about uh we regret
all of the deaths all of the disasters
but this is what's got to got to happen
Hamas has to be put an end to and Israel
needs to provide its own guarantees
because we're not providing
[Applause]
them thank you president I've heard a
lot of colleagues ask why um once again
Europe um is irrelevant on a topic of
foreign policy we've seen uh the
positions adopted by the various
European institutions since the 7th of
October not just in the council but also
the other authorities have expressed uh
differing positions and there have been
uh
personal spats uh arising far too often
in recent weeks
this is not uh because of nationalism
but because of uh personalities about
people who put their own political
careers above shared
interests now of course we welcome the
news that some of the hostages will soon
be released
but if you want to really understand
what's happening and what this chamber
should do you have to understand
understand what happened on the 7th of
October and and what's going on in that
region because the event of the 7th of
October was not uh The Cry of a people
demanding their own sovereignty it was a
terrorist act purped by a um
organization that attacked a state
because that's written into hamas's
statute and that's what Hamas does um
working with its supporters including
Iran and if you can't understand that
then you won't be able to understand the
uh Concrete Solutions that will help us
move forward and you won't be able to
understand uh the support uh that this
chamber these institutions should show
to Israel who live under the constant
threat of
Destruction it's the left uh the um
shortsightedness mean that uh this topic
always is a uh is always a an own
goal
uh you work for minorities uh for LGBT
uh for women and yet at the same time
you're supporting islamist
fundamentalism which denies rights to
women which condemns homosexuals to
death and which cracks down on freedom
thank
you the next speaker is Madame
auri colleagues this morning we are
letting out a breath of
uh the first time for being able to at
least relax somewhat seeing that people
are going to be released they're going
to be able to rejoin their nearest and
dearest and we have to carry on doing
our utmost to release the rest of the
host hostages Gaza has been under these
bombs for many weeks now and they're
hoping that this will soon stop because
the uh death counts is is counting up
and yes people are refusing to condemn
this
14,000 people have being killed
including thousands of women and
children and you've sanctioned that
you've sanctioned bombs on on hospitals
and schools who said nothing about those
crimes but you're always against a
ceasefire because a ceasefire can't just
be a pause it has to be
a longer lasting ceasefire how do we
tell these thousands of parents who've
lost their childrens that their children
that their collateral
damage that uh we shouldn't enter into a
ceasefire with Israel we should look at
the second package of sanctions against
Russia but how at the same time can we
see that nothing is being done against
the war crimes against um Gaza by Israel
this is unacceptable and there have to
be consequences in uh Gaza but also on
the West Bank that we don't talk about
very much where the Crackdown is getting
worse and worse the settlements seem to
have no limits every every year every
day the Palestinians are attacked and
abused and beaten and chased off their
territory it's an form of ethnic
cleansing every Palestinian Village
counts so we must do something and we
have to have a diplomatic solution
because this can only stop once we have
a two-state solution we can we need to
look at what's happening in the in the
Middle East because it will have
ramifications around the world and today
we're at a Tipping Point if the European
Parliament cons contines in being blind
to what's going on it's not just
covering itself in shame but it will
bury permanently international law and
with it the hope of a lasting peace
thank
you Sabrina P Miss Sabrina
pedi good morning Gaza is Hell on Earth
there's no water food medicine newborns
die in intensive care because there's no
electricity schools are bombed as are
ambulances and
hospitals in just a month and a half
over 5,000 children have been killed as
well as uh 200 uh doctors and nurses
over 60 uh media workers and over 100 un
staff it is a blood bath what else has
to happen before we say enough is enough
we condemned the Hamas criminals and
today we must similarly condemn the
criminals of Netanyahu and his army
Europe supports the un uh sec to General
gutterz in their attempt to put an end
to this massacre i' would like to thank
the high representative Joseph Burell
for everything that you're doing but the
European Union is conspicuous by its
absence we have um a large amount of
responsibility for what's happening
because of our inertia let's do some
real diplomacy we have to recognize uh
the state of Palestine and put an end to
economic relations with anyone who kills
civilians tolerating the annihilation of
a people means that we accomplice in
violations of the human rights thank
you Mr M G has the floor now thank you
president ladies and
gentlemen from the outset as the
parliament we wanted to have and we
demand the unrestricted release of the
hostages but now 50 are going to be
released on the basis that 150
Palestinian prisoners will be released
at the same time there'll be a 4 day
ceasefire I'm happy for the families of
those hostages being released what's
regrettable is in the perception of many
Palestinians and Arabs it seems to be
Hamas who's managed to force the
Israelis into these concessions and that
the lengthy peace uh solution has not
come about um because Palestine hasn't
been able to talk to Israel and accept
that they have the right to exist so we
as
Europeans should coordinate our
responses there with the us so we had a
robust mandate for Gaza whether be a
strong International presidents first of
all for humanitarian aid but then for
reconstruction in Gaza that's something
that then has to lead to a process a
peace process where there be elections
that take place and negotiations
for a peace a lasting peace I'm in favor
of Gaza not being allowed to be repeated
and we don't see a further intera in the
West Bank because it has to come we have
to come to a genuine peace process the
floor is
yours thank you Mr President Mr High
representative Mr commissioner first of
all I would like to commend your
statements and personal efforts since
the crisis escalated the role of the
European Union in this crisis could have
enormous importance for our Global role
our relations with the Middle Eastern
countries and other Global Partners EU
must be more engaged by the neighboring
countries should also assist more in
mitigating the effects of this
humanitarian
disaster of course Israel has a right to
defend himself targeting terrorists from
Hamas but the way does must be regarded
through a clear set of rules that are
internationally recognized depriving
civilians of essential Commodities to
survive can't be justified especially if
more than half of Civilian victims are
children the exchange of hostages and
temporary ceasefire are the first
positive steps but many more are needed
to accomplish a sovereign Palestinian
state that is in peace with the state of
Israel a goal that we must continue
pursuing thank
you thank you very much for Vi president
Nicola now our vice president Nicola be
has the floor
president president with all the
Justified concerns to resolve the human
humanitarian crisis in Gaza and to help
the civilian CR uh victims we shouldn't
forget what has happened the trigger for
this uh situation was Hamas every day
Hamas is firing rockets at Israeli
civilians and they're using
humanitarian shields in Gaza it's up to
Hamas to stop the horror and to start
the peace and the liberation of all host
ages must be prerequisite for that but a
real piece has to end hamas's Terror
would it be out of this world to think
that the Palestinians and Israelis could
do this together that we could have
leading personalities involved who could
understand the pain of loss who could
then push to stop this conflict
believing that politicians are going to
see beyond a power struggle and work for
a peaceful coexistence in the future is
that too much to ask this is something
we managed to do after the second world
war we need a new Oslo moment and we as
the EU should do everything to support
it thank
you thank you the next speaker is Miss
Grace O
Sullivan people all over the world are
asking what can we do to stop a war that
has taken 5,000 children from their
mothers and has left an entire
generation
traumatized while the families of
hostages now hold their breath to hear
if love loved ones will be
released EU leaders have entirely failed
to give an answer to that question what
can we do you have failed to call for a
ceasefire you have failed to react to
breaches of international law Gaza is in
run
while settlements in the West Bank
continue to expand Netanyahu and his
far-right government are emboldened by
your silence and so others must Pro
provide the answers where you have
failed here's what you can do demand a
permanent ceasefire now end trade
settlements and trade with settlements
now recognize the Palestinian State now
now the EU must be courageous not
complicit thank
[Applause]
you
for Mr Cano
president today I have a question a
pressing question for some Western
feminists how can you remain silent when
women and girls are raped tortured their
bodies carried around naked and spot on
by birded men shouting
alar then you can never call yourself a
feminist again every day including today
some Western hypocritical feminist
should be ashamed of their silence on
the horror that herass men inflicted to
women and girls on 7 October and that
includes big names we were once proud of
why are their lips sealed and their
hearts of stone when it comes to the
excruciating pain of Jewish Women the me
movement and socalled intersectional
feminists do not care about all women if
they remain silent it means they have
lied to us about their commitment to
Women rights their actions support the
oppressor not the victims also the Au
money does indirectly those who say
nothing about these women and the
hostages should not be standing here and
speaking about human rights when you are
under attack by terrorists a ceasefire
is like like raising your hands when
you're being shot at perhaps it's worth
considering that real lasting ceasefire
will start with bringing back all the
hostages to their homes and the rapist
to
Justice now you are on the speakers
list um our next speaker is Mr Anders
V this discussion is always very
sensitive I don't know I don't think
there's anybody in this chamber who
feels that civilian deaths are not uh
they shouldn't be H they shouldn't
happen at all if they can be avoided
they must be avoided but the rhetoric is
a bit sort of strange here if the UN
Secretary General says that uh we are
witnesses to the biggest loss of
civilians it's unparalleled it hasn't
happened in my time as Secretary General
he said
but let's remind each other and him that
while he's been the Secretary General
the conflict in Syria is still going on
500,000 people have died there in Yemen
the conflict has not been solved 377,000
deaths
Afghanistan
176,000 dead daur 300,000 dead Iraq
400,000
dead and Congo more than 660,000 people
died
there so there is a striking difference
between when Muslims kill Muslims and
Arabs kill Arabs and when Israelis try
and fight Hamas uh when you listen to
the rhetoric in this house and the
rhetoric you hear from the United
Nations let's bear in mind that when you
asked Palestinians both in Gaza and on
the west Brink if they supported the
terrorist attack uh in October three out
of four says yes we support that but is
is has a right to defend itself we have
the right to fight Islamic terrorism and
we must do it until we won the fight
thank you here Manu P the floor is
yours gra
presid thank you
president Mr
borell last
Monday this Parliament refused not just
to ask for a uh ceasefire but to even
debate it there are now
14,1 128 people have been murdered by
Israel in Gaza Strip more than 5,000
children more than 3,000 women 6,000
people have been uh buried by ruins on
the Gaza Strip just in the first 3 weeks
of this genocide there were more
children who died in Gaza than in the
whole of last year in conflicts in the
world how many more Palestinian children
have to be murdered by Israeli bombs for
this European Parliament and the
European Union to ask for a
ceasefire if we talk about hostages let
us require that the 240 Israelis held by
the Palestinians be released and also
the 7,000 Palestinians who are being
held in Israeli prisons or are some of
them more painful to worse than these of
those 7,000 more than 800 are women and
children in Israeli prisons if we really
want peace let us listen to our peoples
our peoples are in the street making the
case for what we're refusing to to press
for uh starting with a ceasefire a
permanent Fair ceasefire not just a
pause secondly that we should take uh
steps we should U take action rather
than just speak words words we should go
beyond these words deeply concerned in
English and uh do something to put an
end to the occupation and thirdly we
should support the initiatives so that
Netanyahu and all of those who are
responsible should be the speaker is
unfortunately cut
off the next speaker is Mr Costas
Papadakis Mr
borell you don't need to be a
lawyer to know that the barbaric actions
of Israel in Gaza are heus crimes
they're bombing hospitals and we hear
fake news that the Israeli
Army uh saying that they have to defend
themselves
but it seems that the object of their
attacks is not Hamas but to avoid the
foundation of a Palestinian
State we're seeing that energy companies
are going to be taking over contracts
there and we condemn what the
various states are bringing about there
for example the Greek stat we don't want
the Palestinian people be to be
massacred many Palestinians
are trying to assert the rights of their
Palestinian people and they're demanding
a Palestinian
state
with south or east Jerusalem as a
capital thank
you thank you
president the 19th of October there was
a huge majority in the European
Parliament to adopt a resolution which
condemned the Hamas
attacks and um regretted the um
suffering of the Palestinian people
being used as a human shield for Hamas
but there were 20 votes against this
resolution of course it's a very small
majority small minority
sorry uh two of them were from former
Spanish
ministers now we've heard that it's very
hard to reach uh agreements within the
council but uh
is the uh of course it is if the these
two ministers and the um Spanish
government now we have the um president
of the commission who've also launched
uh Financial funds that are supposed to
provide aid but if we look at the um
history of Europe you know we've been
discussing this for the last uh two
weeks but when we have to have uh res um
resolutions okay but what about um
financial aid European presence um it
was the Americans who managed to bring
about this um pause this humanitarian P
where were we well of course how can you
be surprised we were absent when we see
who wants in the
council the Flor is your has the
floor
colleagues a small area in the Middle
East cut off from the surrounding areas
where nobody none of the civilian
population are being bombed can find
shelter um care workers children women
are all being attacked
here Gaza is being considered as the
world's biggest outdoor prison the
screeches for peace are being he across
the world here in the parliament as well
in the Swedish right wi the SD but also
the conservative party seem to be deaf
because of their uh enmity towards the
Palestinian people we have to fight
Hamas but we have to at the same time
make sure that innocent Palestinians and
Israelis are protected and that
Palestinians aren't forced out of their
homes yesterday's agreement between the
Palestinians and the Israelis is
important but let's not forget the rules
of War have to be respected by all
parties at all time the EU has to
contribute with humanitarian Aid support
the Palestinian Authority stop this
suffering and push for a permanent
two-state solution so Palestine is
recognized as a state so that that
Palestine and Israel can be in peace and
commissioner lenich for your important
work but I also must say that I'm
ashamed of commissioner V and his
actions thank
you
missa the floor is
yours in our 27 Capital Cities and in
Washington and all of countries of the
Arab League the talk is all about about
the two states Israeli and Palestine
States many people don't want to believe
it but Palestine will actually come into
being alongside the state of Israel for
the simple reason that there's no other
possibility for this what to this
100-year war but who people ask Will
expel the 500,000 settlers well a
minority will put up future resistance
most of them will will go back to Israel
and others will become foreign residents
in this new state that's not the real
problem the real problem is that reason
Good Sense doesn't have enough Defenders
on on either side of this and that's why
peace just and Lasting peace will have
to be imposed from the outside just as
the partition of 1947 was imposed by the
United Nations then our Union will have
a fundamental role to play so rather
than arguing about words truth or
ceasefire our Parliament should be
preparing
urgently fully for that role when peace
takes breaks out thank
you Miss Hannah noyman has the
floor as we debate families in Israel
are mourning children
parents spouses barbarically killed by
Hamas terrorists on October 7 they fear
for the Liv of hostages and they are
seeking shelter from ongoing Hamas
shelling in
Gaza people are mourning their children
parents spouses who have become victims
of Israel's shelling of Civilian
infrastructure they fear for those who
remain exposed to ongoing air strikes
and suffer under the SI of
Gaza all human beings have the right to
live in safety and freedom demanding
this for one group does not question
this right in relation to another group
empathy is not a serero SU
game the announced release of hostages
linked to a temporary truce offers a new
glimpse of Hope to end the spiral of
violence the European Union together
with the UN Arab states and the US must
facilitate a process where both Israelis
and Palestinians can work on solutions
to live side by side in peace hopefully
for good this
[Applause]
time next speaker is Mr
fragos thank you president without a
doubt um those responsible for the the
situation in Gaza are the United States
who financed the Taliban in Afghanistan
and also
Hamas um to try to damage fata and
Arafat another uh key uh person
responsible is erdogan who did not
hesitate to support the terrorist
organization Hamas so we here Mr Bell
ask ourselves how can the European Union
uh talk about and finance this dictator
erdogan the European Union should not
accept any Muslim extremist on their own
ter territory not even the Arab
countries do that it's shameful uh to
talk about
this uh we should not be accepting any
illegal migrants onto our
territory Mr Tim you have the
floor president
president neither in the course of War
nor during the release of hostages
during this conflict have we had any
impact the EU is left to one side in
political terms it's not even an extra
in this
film it' be more important to have a
debate here in this house to talk about
the consequences in Europe would have to
be
drawn the anti-semitic demonstrations of
the overwhelming Muslim mobs on our
streets
should be a wakeup call there's urgent
need to act to stop islamization in
Europe but following these
demonstrations of power what's happened
were islamists um deported were
organizations banned were illegal
migrants rejected nothing of that sort
in Germany we're seeing Taliban
officials enter the our state without
the knowledge of the authorities to
spread hate how long are we going to
stand and watch are we going to wait
until we're
overrun we have to combat isz before
it's too late let's concentrate on what
we can do and not just on our pipe
dreams
is Mr Miroslav rovski has the
floor colleagues attitude of us
Europeans towards the Jewish Nation is
not honest and hypocritical during
centuries we have liquidated a Jewish
nation that was Holocaust we killed 6
million innocent
Jews we were not able to live together
with them we created a state for them
and because we were unable to live with
them we told Palestinians you must live
with them you must live with
them but not under similar conditions
not as equals
israelian got their own State
Palestinians uh Gaza Strip Western Bank
of Jordan occupied territory without a
capital without a vision for future and
this is the main
reason why we are witnessing what is
happening today in the Middle East and I
repeat what I
said uh two weeks
ago nobody will be able to
destroyed Jewish Nation but nobody will
be able to
destroy Palestinian
Nation let us start talk about peace let
us ask for the creation of a Palestinian
State that's the future thank you very
much Mr halitsky has the floor dear
colleagues I would like to emphasize
dramatic situation of children in
Palestine we cannot be blind
5,000 kids were killed
700,000 are displaced because their
houses are
destroyed thousands are injured there is
lack of water electricity children have
to be protected but this is not the only
situation in Gaza Street in West Bank
territory 11 years old girl was
sentenced to prison
on 12
years this is
cruelty we have to protect
children we cannot accept it as European
Parliament we have to react and I call
European institutions to act and to
react children are innocent and there is
no black and white scenario the war is
not solution we have to protect kids
children hospitals schools have to be
protected stop this war thank you thank
you for Elena yeva the floor is
yours thank you president dear
colleagues the humanitarian situation in
Gaza is unsupportable there's more than
900,000 people have been dis placed uh
who uh need to be put up by the United
Nations there are 17 facilities that are
directly affected by the conflict so
this is appalling instead of discussing
ways in which further conditions should
be laid on the provision of Aid the EU
should be bringing pressure to better be
sorry for more humanitarian corridors so
as to uh relieve the situation in Gaza
the conflict goes beyond the borders of
Israel and Gaza right now
uh there's been a cargo that has been uh
uh um hijacked in Yemen and uh there are
Romanian and Bulgarian uh crew members
in involved what measures do you plan to
take Mr Borel and others to uh ensure
that the people on that vessel can be
freed what measures are you planning to
take thank you rri
R Rodriguez Ramos
graas thank you president a ray of Hope
today with the freeing of Israeli
hostages and a
4-day ceasefire but we all know that
this is far from being enough what's
happening in Gaza is appalling Gaza is
now a uh
grave with more than
16,000 bodies in it and we are not doing
enough to prevent this humanitarian
catastrophe the EU would not allow any
other country to infringe the basic uh
provisions of international law the
protection of civilians the protection
of humanitarian Personnel protection of
the press Banning attacks on hospitals
International humanitarian law and its
fulfillment is what separates Democratic
countries from uh autocratic countries
and from terrorist organizations so our
double standards here when it comes to
the defense of Human Rights and the
defense of international law here uh
is
intolerable and this is something that
we're going to have to pay the bill for
later on when it comes to this ultimate
solution which is a two-state
solution thank you Mr
M first of all thank you thank you Mr
Bell uh given the cacophony and um lack
of responsibility you have been able to
um make your voice heard and I would
like to welcome two pieces of news
possible a hostage release this is a
very good news and is encouraging um
when it comes to a sustainable long-
lasting
ceasefire and uh the proof that we have
never financed uh Hamas uh commissioner
uh Val who um tried to blame the
European Union um and should uh leave um
it's a question of the honor of the
EU it has to be clear in the world that
uh we are support peace um stability
international law we promote uh human
rights that's our job that's our role so
we have to demand this we have the means
to achieve that we are the first
economic and uh trade partners of Israel
um and uh Finance the Palestinian
Authority we have uh the tools we have
to activate our sanctions regime against
anyone who attack human rights and we
have to demand a sustainable peaceful
solution uh two states that's the only
way we're going to see stability in the
world thank
youan
R ban Ron you have the
floor thank you president High
representative
commissioner to all of those who believe
that CR that criticism is to be leveled
at Israel including Mr barell I'd like
to put the following question who has
been holding more than 200 innocent
citizens as hostage for more than a
month yes
Hamas who on the 7th of October spread
death and destruction on a peaceful
music festival and in and several kotes
exactly Hamas and who is using innocent
citizens as a human shield exactly
Hamas I'm sure everything needs to be
done to try and release all hostages as
soon as possible we've seen the terror
and misery in the eyes of their
relatives who have terrible stories to
tell but there seems to be an agreement
on a release of a first group of
hostages and that's promising but let's
not forget that in order to have a
lasting peace Hamas has to be taken out
of operation Israel deserves our
support dead children by indiscriminate
attacks men women civilians killed just
because they're
Palestinian including newborns new
newborns dying in incubators because
they've Switched Off electricity to
hospitals that's what's going on in
Palestine these is uh all um the
responsibility of
Netanyahu I in this chamber have asked
Europe to condemn these violations of
human rights this Terror and nothing's
happened we rightly condemned the
terrorist attack by Hamas and the acts
of war from uh Putin's Russia but why
are we waiting to condemn netanyahu's
criminal Behavior it's shameful um to
accuse people of anti-Semitism when they
criticize this Israeli
government are there Israelis around the
world speaking out about Netanyahu who's
crimes uh what is Europe doing uh what
about those children whose family
members have died who are without
heating uh are we going to tolerate
these um violations of human rights uh
no um Palestinian children are being
killed by netanyahu's choices and we
have to take a position now otherwise we
are guilty of um dirty hypocrisy is Miss
Anna Michelle Miss Anna Michelle Asim
mopo has the floor thank you Mr
President bring them back home that was
the The Desperate Cry of the families of
the hostages that were brutally abducted
by the terrorist organization Hamas when
it launched its heinous attack on Israel
on October 7th today it appears 50
hostages are going to be released as
part of a deal that includes the release
of 50 Palestinian prisoners in a
4-day um humanitarian pause and of
course we welcome this development and
hope it leads to more positive
developments Israel has indicated its
willingness to continue to discuss the
humanitarian pauses in exchange for
release of the
hostages today I would like us not to
forget that there are another 200
families that are desperate at this
moment that are in excruciating pain
that are wondering about their loved
ones and and to them I would like to
say that bring them home means bring
them all back home thank
you thank
you Mr Nao Sanchez more the floor is
yours I'd like to thank you for your
impeccable political position but also
uh your diplomatic position Mr borrow uh
Mr Bor in the face of the situation I'm
afraid that the uh commission started in
a very poor fashion the damage was done
uh by the commissioner Vani at the
outset and today they've simply
described the situation but Mr borell I
wish to warn you and your colleagues
about the
uh dangers that we're running when it we
allow people to say that the EU has
double standards in the face of local
recent conflicts in some cases this is
the case and others it's not but there's
a danger that our soft power be taken
away we have our principles we have our
values we can't uh allow ourselves to
give the world this dangerous image of
moral inconsistency by having differing
approaches to different military uh
conflicts with preventive uh excuses so
far as this chamber is concerned our
guide is respect for international law
without any prefence without any
exceptions and the we are as concerned
and regretful about the dead be they
Israeli or
Palestine you
have today the whole of the Middle East
is being held hostage of course I'm
thinking about the 237 hostages being
held by hamus all the men women all the
children they should all be allowed to
go home but I'm also thinking of the 2
million garans they're also being held
hostage by hamus it's us Europeans who
are concerned about their fate and who
are um in the first place when it comes
to giving Aid to the Palestinians hamus
is building tunnels not schools they buy
arms not
medicines they don't help the
Palestinian cause they use it for
personal gain and to F fuel their insane
anti-semitic islamist plans and I'm
thinking about peace peace that was
sketched out in the Oslo Accords and
whose Craftsmen are now dead Arafat is
gone and in Palestine now who has his
courage his C courage to fight for peace
Rabin was assassinated today the Israeli
extremists encourage is Israeli settlers
to go after Palestinians in the West
Bank they have no design for a future in
the for Gaza in the future apart from
destruction they have betrayed Rabin and
taken peace hostage we uh Europeans know
what islamist terrorism is and we
express our solidarity with the Israeli
people we Europeans know uh and
understand the suffering of the
Palestinian people and I would like to
thank you um commissioner lenich for
your bold uh positions and for your
Relentless efforts um you do us an honor
it's the um Israelis and Palestinians
who have to work together to build peace
together
this the speaker has been cut off come
to the end our next speaker is Mr Deo
hak
thank you
president what if your home were
destroyed
Rockets would be uh sent and so on what
would you do would you take
counteraction of course you would or you
would release your home to the enemies
uh Jews are being attacked all the time
every day can we even start
negotiations Hamas says that every Jew
should be abolished on the from the
world on this basis we cannot expect
peace with these people in Hamas Gaza
population is taken hostage by Hamas
Hamas holds every Palestinian person
hostage and now the European Union has
funded Palestinians but actually all
this money has gone to hammer terrorists
they've built tunnels underneath
hospitals and other civilian
infrastructure
thank you Mr President Commissioners I
want to talk about hostages I want to
talk about the over 200 Israeli women
children and Men whom amas kidnapped on
October 7th and I to talk about the
Palestinians in Gaza whom Hamas has
taken Hostage to and while I welcome the
positive news about a possible deal it
is still vital to stress that Hamas must
release all hostages all hostages The
Vicious Terror organization Hamas said
on annihilating the state of Israel has
butchered Israelis raped women in front
of their children burned humans alive
but Hamas is also tormenting
Palestinians in Gaza blocking their
escape using them as human Shields
refusing basic rights torturing people
for being gay silencing women Hamas
leaves no hope for the future of Gaza
and for the people of Gaza that they
claim to represent Kamas must be
defeated from The River To The Sea all
hostages must be free thank
you thank
you
now Udo Bulman has the
floor president
president ladies and
gentlemen if we can get hostages
liberated if we can have ceasefires
which hold then these are important and
correct steps to take but it's
insufficient in and of
itself the people in the death zone of
Israel the people in the death zone
of Gaza need more than that
and yes Mr Bell's correct we have to
look towards peace but what does that
mean it means for the European Union
that we have to have the strength and
courage to take that
path people in Israel have to be able to
live in peace and safety where are the
representatives of
the Arab neighboring states to help
guarantee that where are the friends of
Israel who make it abundantly clear that
no more innocent people may die and that
violence uh Must Be
Stopped commissioner High representative
let's be part of the solution let us be
part of the solution that stops this
spiral of death once and for all okay no
thank you very much now Mr Lucas Mandel
has the floor feel thank
thank you very much vice president obar
caras High representative yes the has to
be a
ceasefire all
the organizations like the Islamic guard
Hamas Hezbollah all these Iranian funded
organizations have to be stopped they
have to be stopped in the EU as well if
we can stop that violence there will be
no more is
uh Islamic fundamentalist terrorism but
we in the European Parliament we're here
in our comfy seats and we can decide
when the right time is for a truce and
for the release of um hostages no we
can't decide that it's the um Israeli
soldiers our representative Partners
there the Israeli
government but some may never return and
that's more than a thousand women uh
children and Men who've been killed by
this Islamic attack they're never going
to return home so I'd call Muslims to
distance themselves from the
anti-Semitism that we're seeing uh
claing its way back into Europe and it
should be fought with the utmost uh
harsh uh application of laws and those
who are responsible for the 7th of
October attacks must be brought to
Justice the next speaker is Miss
Isabelle
Santos
High representative commissioner I'd
like to begin by expressing gratitude
for the clear sightedness the firmness
the determination that's been shown at
times when there's been a sort of uh
cacophony uh in general which threatened
uh our having a a reasonable view on the
Middle
East
we have I was in touch with an NGO that
stated our teams that we have uh in uh
Palestine are exhausted there Beyond
hope we're having children who are being
operated on and having limbs amputed
without anesthetic on the floor of
hospitals when you hear that there's not
much more than he saying the right to uh
of Israel to defend itself against
hamas's attacks is legitimate if it's
thoroughly bracketed limited by
international law it's enough already of
uh insincere words we have hopes about
trues and so on but it's not enough the
EU needs to be committed to ensuring the
end of
violence in the West Bank as
well this is the only way to ensure
peace thank you speaker is Mr Alexandro
you Mr President Mr
borell let us commend Israel for its
efforts to have the hostage is
released but it should be clear that as
long as Hamas exists the humanitarian
disaster will continue and there will be
no peace there is one single solution
this destruction of Hamas hisbah and all
other terrorist organizations in the
region as to the civilian population in
Gaza
obviously it is not that peaceful when
males become
terrorists that population supports
Hamas we need further sanctions against
the countries that support terrorism
mainly
Iran but also
Russia there should be peace in
Palestinian State when there is no
Palestinian terrorism any longer free
Palestine means Hamas free Palestine
thank
you thank you very
much thank you president High
representative uh there are negotiations
underway and they seem to be leading to
a possible at truce and hostage release
we hope that this happens as quickly as
possible so this leaves room for a bit
of optimism but also uh we have to see
that there is a tragic situation on the
ground over a month after the criminal
attacks by Hamas we seeing an increase
in the deaths in Gaza uh they do not
have um basic Commodities fuel food
medicines uh this is a tragic situation
and you yourself High representative I
think rightly set out the path we have
to follow we need to see an immediate
end to hostilities to ensure that
humanitarian Aid can get into Gaza uh it
should not be reoccupied by Israel we
don't want to see forced expulsion of
Palestinians uh I'll repeat what I've
already said in this chamber Israel has
a right to defend itself but not to uh
enact Revenge civilians have to be
protected uh We've shown that we the
European Union can speak with its own
with our own voice and play a diplomatic
role we have to continue to do this and
we can't wait we need to see an end to
this war
thank thank you Mr Lucas
F president commissioner Mr Burell the
developments in
Gaza and the
ceasefire sorry the truce that's been
called for now gives a glimmer of hope
from the outset we have condemned the
Hamas terrorist attack we're in favor of
the right of Israel to defend itself and
we've also announced that civilians
cannot be made victims ladies and
gentlemen we have to find a solution for
this humanitarian problem Mr Burell
Cyprus has undertaken actions to try and
open a humanitarian
Corridor to the Middle
East Cyprus is working on the ground and
we're in favor of the humanitarian issue
being resolved Mr barell I'm very
pleased that you've supported this
initiative it's an initiative that is
not just cypriate but European as well
thank
you now we have the following problem in
a few minutes we will be having our
guest
speaker today the prime minister of
Bulgaria who will be here in the
chamber so I
would say that there are many people who
have asked for the floor under catch the
ey I cannot take all of them I'm oblig
only to take
five and so I have to meet the gendera
balance and a balance between the
political groups as well and secondly I
would call on the the council and the
commission to stick to the allocated
speaking time I'll start the catch the
ey procedure with Miss Yanina
oosa thank you very much president I
think we should strike the right balance
when discussing the conflict between
Israel and Palestine yes we should
demand that all the hostages be released
we should demand as ceas fire we should
criticize Israel for this for its
retaliation while condemning Hamas and
other terrorist organization we should
put an end to this terrorism I will
never forget a girl from Palestine who
had a wound in her face and lost her
hands but I will never forget either the
bodies of the Jews murdered by Hamas we
need a stable people PE this is starting
with forgiveness and dialogue thank
youa thank you Mr R
DEA thank you very much dear president
otar caras my thanks to the high
representative and Vice President Joseph
Borel and to commissioner AIC I think we
should be congratulating the
High representative for his tour around
the countries of the Middle East I think
it's been a very useful visit to make
sure that the eu's position is clear I
think it's also necessary uh to
reiterate that
uh we in the EU are against Palestine no
longer controlling the Gaza Strip the
future of the Gaza
Strip or rather are we uh are in favor o
of Hamas not doing that anymore it
should be uh Palestinian Authority with
support of United Nations and others and
from there on in the two- State
solution and uh the EU should be
assessing the possibility of uh putting
forward a European Union peace plan as
the US have in the past I think that
would give added value to the European
Union if we could put forward a peace
plan to support the peace process thank
you thank you
for ab thank you very much Miss AB Alani
the floor is
yours we have no time please yes uh
thank you uh Mr President allow me to
start with apologizing to the children
of Gaza on our disappointing position so
far we have let them down we have let
their lives be taken away from them and
not defended their equal right to
life and let me thank also Mr Burell for
finally raising his voice in in a just
way standing up for all hum or All
Humans human rights because if something
that has been very clear and strongly
shown is that we have applied double
standards when it comes to implementing
human rights for all the people of Gaza
the Palestinians have been treated with
double standards and that's just a fact
yesterday I listened to the Israeli
former Ambassador Eli baravi and he said
that we have to show courage that means
that we have to now start to force both
sides to the peace negotiations we have
to have a marshal plan for Gaza and we
have to recognize the state of Palestine
and bring on the americ thank you uh
from Margaret o Miss Margaret
for thank you Appel for an excellent
speech there is a point that we haven't
talked about today at all is the uh
threat that's happening in Lebanon nine
people were killed yesterday two
reporters and an old women 45 or 46,000
have been internally
displaced olive trees have been cut down
and uh White phospher has been used on
them let me quote what the Israeli
Minister for defense gallon said he's
saying it's it's all over the Arab media
now what we are doing in Gaza we can do
in
byut I think we have to pay a lot of
attention to that serious threat that
might be hitting us all uh because uh we
do not see the things that are happening
at the moment also in Beirut and in
Lebanon they have strong Recollections
of what they were exposed to so we
cannot guarantee that they'll just sit
with their hands folded and hope that
things go well we have to be much
tougher there I know that Bell knows
this I think we all should know that
thank
you the last speaker is Mr ladisl ilich
under catch
the dear colleagues uh you've said that
Israel is killing civilians and you've
used this as an argument to condemn
Israel so each piece of news about a
killed civilian thus damages Israel and
is beneficial to Hamas so it's clear why
Hamas wouldn't uh let civilians go but
rather it uses them as human shield
you've called for ceasefire but during
the ceasefire Hamas will surely not sit
uh idle it will regroup group and bring
additional weapons how come you have not
called for a complete disarmament of
Hamas how come you have not called for
elections in Gaza all of you condemning
Israel here today you are protecting
Hamas you are protecting terrorism and
you are importing that terrorism into
Europe so when Israel is destroying
Hamas today it is uh doing a service to
all of us
Now we move to the council and
commission for comments turning first to
commissioner
linic Mr President uh honorable members
uh I listened very carefully to all the
interventions and I would like to
summarize my concluding remarks in the
following Five Points one there can be
no doubt that the international
humanarian law applies fully in this
conflict as in any other conflict and it
is binding on all part
parties and it is also quite obvious
that International humanitarian law is
not being
respected large numbers of civilians
have been killed in Israel on 7th of
October hostages were taken Rockets have
been fired indiscriminately across
Israel more than 12,000 civilians have
been killed in
Gaza humanitarian Aid is being
obstructed more than 100 un stuff have
been killed and so on these are
violations of international humanitarian
law and they have to
stop second it is
urgent to improve humanitarian access
into Gaza and within Gaza now let me
explain what this means in practice with
the help of the UN Security Council
resolution adopted last week resolution
number
272 which says inter Alia
what this access means it means I quote
urgent and extended humanitarian poses
and corridors throughout the Gaza Strip
for a sufficient number of
days to facilitate the
continuous sufficient and unhindered
provision of essential goods and
services throughout again throughout the
Gaza Strip including water
electricity fuel food and medical
supplies as well as emergency repairs to
essential
infrastructure and so on this is the law
this is what the law says and we still
have not seen it complied with fully by
all parties to this conflict third point
I also wish to stress the importance of
the role of the United Nations the role
of the United Nations in humanitarian
assistance to Palestinian territories is
indispensable and I want to say that
very clearly because United Nations has
been attacked by some recently and I
just want to make it clear that without
them there can be no meaningful
humanitarian assistance to Gaza and
other parts of Palestinian territory
fourth for us as the European Union and
our member states it is essential to
step up humanitarian response both in
kind and in funding and the European
commission is committed to doing its
part and finally my fifth Point while we
our Focus has been on Gaza we should not
lose sight of the deteriorating
situation in the West Bank and we should
step up our efforts on the political
front towards a two State solution thank
you
thank thank you very much now Vice
President of the commission and high
representative Joseph borell has the
Flor thank you
president as I said at the beginning we
should be able to uh weigh up both side
of the
scales again uh we have to say um and
repeat uh what happened on the 7th of
October
is something that we absolutely condemn
there is no justification for it um not
um in a defense against uh colonization
settlements or to build a Palestinian
State
no it's not a question of whether the
Palestinians have a right to defend
themselves the 7th of October wasn't an
act of Defense it was an act of
terrorism they attacked uh Civ civilians
in a premeditated
way and I can repeat that as many times
as you want because it seems that some
people uh don't want to hear
it we also have to be clear that uh uh
Molotov cocktails thrown about against
uh synagogues in Berlin or slogans
against Jews in
Sydney have nothing to do with uh
showing solidarity with the Palestinian
people it's just the old hatred against
Jewish people uh that was responsible
for some of the worst periods in
European history and that we have to
fight every single day without exception
and without any
doubt do you want me to repeat
it we can repeat it every
day uh but that doesn't mean we can
ignore what's happening in the West Bank
uh settlements that are counter to un
resolutions and it doesn't mean that we
can uh minimize the errors that have
been committed by both sides and this
tragedy that's been going on for far too
long if we want to talk about laws uh
and
rights uh we should listen to those who
are responsible for implementing it the
um prosecutor of the international
criminal
court uh their role should not be based
on emotion but on uh clear objective
proof and uh the ICC is carrying out the
uh necessary investigations into what we
see as a um uh tragedy and um acts
against people without
defense um we cannot mix up emotion and
reason uh of course uh emotions run very
high in this that part of the world but
we have to try to move Beyond emotions
to set out the path that we can travel
together to try to search for peace
peace cannot be built on Military
destruction by a terrorist organization
Pete will be built on the hope of the
Palestinian people uh their hope to live
in Liberty and
dignity without this there will be no
peace and peace isn't just something
that we want to see for
moral reasons uh here today we talk
about the necess the need of for virtue
but it's virtue but it's not just a
question of virtue it's a
necessity and uh Israel needs a
Palestinian State more than anyone
because the best guarantee of peace and
security for Israel is the existence of
a Palestinian State that's
um written into international law and
respects
uh Israel's rights to survive that's
what we have to invest
in um it don't want to get uh bogged
down into Spanish Affairs uh Spanish
wasn't um the presidency of the European
uh Council it's uh sha Michelle who is
the um president of the council it's not
the Spanish government and they don't
have uh we have the um presidency the
rotating presidency but that's something
quite
different uh the responsibility for
international has been uh transferred to
the high representative so if you want
to criticize someone criticize
me and I've also heard your support as
well as your criticism but it's very
difficult believe me to find the right
balance when everyone feels pain and
nobody wants to talk about uh what's
going to happen in the future because
everyone is focused on today on the
moment uh we want to see an end to
herass but also an end to not to see any
more deaths but there will be um a day
after and when that day comes that's
when European the European Union will
have a date with history we have to
contribute
more and not just um to try to minimize
the damage that's already happened but
we have to ensure that it doesn't happen
again uh my colleague Janes was
referring to the humanitarian Aid that
they're so ad admirably um providing but
we also need a political commitment to
ensure uh that this uh humanitarian Aid
um is not just used to um heal wounds
because it's pointless healing wounds if
people will die under bombs the next day
we need humanitarian aid but also
political commitment uh we need to see
both and I hope that this Parliament
will actively contribute to this the
solutions and will be able to come
overcome its differences thank
[Applause]
youle ladies and gentlemen thank you
very
much this was a very important and
intensive debate and I would ask
colleagues who wanted to take the floor
and catch the eye and who weren't
allowed to take the floor I ask them
to indulge my actions it wasn't possible
unfortunately this moves on to moves us
on to the next item on our agenda this
is Europe with Nikolai denov the prime
minister of
Bulgaria